Trascrizione: Alessia Banka
Revisore: Matteo Maggiò
La crisi climatica
è la più grande minaccia esistenziale
che l’essere umano
si sia mai trovato ad affrontare.
La scienza ce lo dice da decenni,
ma in realtà l’abbiamo visto anche noi
con i nostri occhi.
Soprattutto nelle ultime due estati,
caratterizzate da incendi incontrollabili,
alluvioni,
frane letali.
È il problema che più di tutti
sta cambiando il nostro modo
di vivere su questo pianeta.
Eppure, l’immagine che abbiamo utilizzato
per tanto tempo per raccontarlo
è questa.
Se vi torna familiare
è perché ce l’hanno propinata
in qualsiasi salsa per 40 anni,
nel tentativo di smuovere
le nostre coscienze all’azione.
Ma che cosa ci dice questa immagine?
Ci dice che c’è un problema, certo.
Ci dice anche
che noi siamo i responsabili.
Ma ci dice anche
che questo problema non ci riguarda,
perché tendenzialmente,
nella nostra quotidianità non ci sono
né zattere di ghiaccio né orsi polari.
C’è invece un’immagine molto più efficace,
a mio avviso,
che riguarda sempre gli orsi polari.
Questa.
Tra il dicembre 2019
e il febbraio 2020,
questo villaggio della Russia artica
è stato preso d’assalto
da un branco di orsi polari.
Persone che avevano
sempre visto questi animali
come innocue apparizioni all’orizzonte,
d’un tratto
se li sono visti arrivare in massa.
Ad abbattere le porte a zampate,
ribaltare i cassonetti,
seminare il panico nelle strade.
Quello che succedeva
è che questi animali
stanno vedendo il loro habitat
sempre più degradato
e quindi si spostano sempre di più
negli insediamenti umani per trovare cibo.
Il tema di questa edizione di TED
è Apocalypsis
e Apocalypsis in greco
significa letteralmente sollevare il velo.
Il problema
è che la crisi climatica
è coperta da un velo
molto spesso e molto pesante.
Questa immagine ci dice
che c’è un problema,
che noi ne siamo responsabili,
che questo problema ci riguarda.
Ma ci dice anche altre due cose.
Ci dice che ogni separazione
tra natura e esseri umani è illusoria.
E che la crisi climatica
ogni giorno ci sta mostrando
un mondo diverso
da quello che siamo abituati a pensare.
Solo che se è vero
che è la più grande minaccia esistenziale,
è anche vero che è quella
che siamo meno equipaggiati a
prendere sul serio.
C’è una frase di Goethe
che riassume il problema perfettamente
secondo me:
[Vediamo solo ciò
di cui andiamo in cerca
e andiamo in cerca
solo di ciò che conosciamo.]
Allora, per dare un po di sostanza
a quella che sembra una frase teorica,
voglio fare un gioco con voi.
Ora io vi mostrerò
alcune delle immagini che ho scattato
durante un mio viaggio
alla ricerca di luoghi
che già sono colpiti dalla crisi climatica
e dove già la crisi climatica
sta cambiando il nostro modo di vivere.
Vi mostrerò un’immagine adesso
e vorrei che voi pensate
a cosa c’è che non va in questa immagine.
Sembra che sia tutto a posto.
Anzi, sembra il ritratto
di un luogo paradisiaco.
Ed è esattamente quello
che io ho detto ad Hassan,
la persona
che mi ha portato qui.
Questa è Thulusdhoo,
un’isola delle Maldive.
Le Maldive
sono una delle nazioni
che per prima
rischia di sparire dalle cartine
per colpa dell’innalzamento delle acque.
E quando io ho detto ad Assan questa cosa,
lui sorridendo mi ha detto:
Certo, tu vedi un paradiso
perché non eri qui dieci anni fa
e perché non stai osservando
con abbastanza attenzione.
E allora io ho provato
a osservare con più attenzione.
E in effetti,
se voi provate ad aguzzare la vista,
vi rendete conto che la palma più piccola
è sorretta da un bastone.
E basta questo piccolo dettaglio
per far scattare degli ingranaggi diversi
nella nostra testa.
Il nostro sguardo comincia a cambiare
e noi cominciamo a renderci conto
di cose che prima non vedevamo magari.
Ad esempio,
che la spiaggia ha un aspetto strano,
forma una cunetta
e man mano che questa cunetta sale,
le palme si raddrizzano.
A quel punto
torna molto più utile rendersi conto,
è molto più facile rendersi conto
che queste palme
non sono inclinate dal vento.
Stanno crollando
per colpa dell’erosione costiera.
Quindi quello che per me
è un luogo paradisiaco,
per Hassan
è il ritratto della decadenza.
Qui invece siamo a Pointe-aux-Chênes,
in Luisiana.
Allora, anche qui
abbiamo a che fare con quello che sembra
una normalissima località portuale.
In realtà,
dove voi vedete dell’acqua,
fino a 30-40 anni fa,
c’era un prato, mucche che pascolavano.
E in effetti,
se aguzziamo la vista anche qui
vedremo pali della luce
emergere dalle acque.
Cosa significa questo?
Che non ci possiamo più fidare
del nostro sguardo?
No.
Significa che
noi siamo abituati a pensare
che i nostri occhi siano in grado
di cogliere la realtà nella sua interezza.
Ma non è proprio così
Perché la nostra mente
tende a formare degli schemi mentali
in modo
da non dover continuamente aggiornare
i valori che arrivano dall’esterno.
Questo fa sì che noi ci creiamo delle
immagini mentali dei luoghi
e anche di tante altre cose,
che poi sovrapponiamo alla realtà
e questo spesso ci impedisce di vedere
quanto un luogo sia già degradato.
Voi conoscerete benissimo
ovviamente Venezia.
Di Venezia abbiamo un’immagine mentale
molto potente, molto fissa,
tanto che continua a sembrarmi
un gioiello intoccabile,
anche se nell’ultimo secolo le acque
si sono già alzate di 30 centimetri.
E diversi monumenti,
diversi edifici,
si stanno già consumando
per colpa dell’acqua salata.
Cosa succede
quando noi guardiamo queste immagini?
Cosa succede nella nostra testa
quando noi cerchiamo
di incamerare i segni deldeclino
e non ce la facciamo?
Per rispondere a questa domanda
voglio fare un altro esperimento con voi.
Voglio che voi pensiate
al vostro animale preferito.
Ce l'avete un'immagine chiara nella testa
del vostro animale preferito?
Allora, se la statistica non m’inganna,
alcuni di voi avranno pensato
a uno diquesti dieci animali.
Allora, questa non è una classifica
che ho fatto io in maniera arbitraria,
è presa da uno studio intitolato
“La paradossale estinzione
degli animali più carismatici”
Frank Courchamp e altri colleghi
dell’Università di Parigi,
sono andati dalle persone,
hanno fatto una domanda
come quella che io ho fatto a voi:
qual è il vostro animale preferito?
L’idea era di prendere le risposte
e confrontare questa lista
con l’effettivo stato di conservazione
di questi animali.
Anche perché,
quando si andava a chiedere alle persone
quale fosse il loro animale preferito,
la maggioranza era convinta
che questi animali
non fossero a rischio di estinzione.
In realtà però , molti degli animali
che vedete qui sono a rischio estinzione,
in particolare i primi tre:
La tigre, il leone, l'elefante.
Nel caso dell’elefante africano di foresta
solo negli ultimi 9 anni,
si sono persi il 62% degli esemplari.
Com'è possibile?
È possibile perché noi non vediamo,
tendenzialmente,
questi animali nel loro
habitat naturale,
ma li vediamo in
continuazione rappresentati.
Nei documentari, nei film,
sulle scatole dei cereali,
nei cartoni animati.
E quindi,
Il nostro cervello tende a sviluppare
un’immagine mentale di questi animali
e convincerci che vada tutto bene.
Come avrete intuito,
questa cecità selettiva
non riguarda soltanto i luoghi
e gli animali che ci circondano.
È applicabile a diversi aspetti
della nostra vita.
Diversi aspetti che ci rendono difficile
renderci conto di quella che, appunto,
è la più grande minaccia esistenziale
che stiamo affrontando.
E in particolare questo è vero,
perché il nostro sistema d’allarme
tende a non attivarsi
a causa della crisi climatica
e causa del riscaldamento globale.
E per capire perché ,
dobbiamo prima ricordare
che noi esseri umani siamo degli animali
e come tutti gli animali,
siamo il prodotto
di un percorso evolutivo.
Questo significa
che  le nostre caratteristiche
mentali e fisiche
sono quelle che hanno aiutato
i nostri antenati
a sopravvivere in un mondo
molto diverso da questo.
Un mondo in cui, per dire, le minacce
erano molto più inquadrabili
e molto più immediate.
E a questo proposito,
lo psicologo sociale Daniel Gilbert
ha individuato
quattro tipologie di stimolo
che riescono ad attivare
il nostro sistema d’allarme.
Noi tendiamo a entrare in allarme
quando la minaccia
è personale,
improvvisa,
immorale
e attuale.
La crisi climatica
è un problema complesso, stratificato,
distribuito nello spazio e nel tempo,
non riconducibile a un singolo nemico,
dunque non tocca nessuno di questi tasti.
Il risultato è che noi non riusciamo
a sviluppare una paura viscerale
per la crisi climatica.
Ma c’è di più ,
perché l’evoluzione purtroppo
ci ha dato in eredità
anche una serie di limiti cognitivi
che ci rendono difficile
renderci conto del problema.
Ad esempio, abbiamo la tendenza a pensare
che se anche qualcosa di brutto
stia per succedere,
succederà prima a qualcun altro,
in un altro posto, rispetto a noi.
Abbiamo la tendenza,
quando ci dicono che qualcosa di brutto
sta per succedere,
a controllare cosa stanno facendo
le persone intorno a noi
prima di entrare in allarme noi stessi.
E questo è l'effetto spettatore.
Ma soprattutto,
abbiamo la tendenza a pensare
che il mondo in cui viviamo
non potrà cambiare più di tanto
e tendiamo a preferire
che non cambi più di tanto,
soprattutto se ci abbiamo investito
a livello economico, a livello emotivo.
Questi sono il bias di status quo
e l’errore costo effetto.
Il vero problema è anche che
questi limiti cognitivi
non soltanto ci rendono difficile
prendere atto della crisi climatica,
ma ci rendono difficile anche
trovare delle vie per affrontarle,
per uscirne.
Fino a prova contraria,
l’essere umano è l’unico animale
che è in grado di fare
quello che i neurologi chiamano
viaggio nel tempo mentale.
Ossia noi siamo in grado di proiettare
un’immagine di noi
nel passato, quando ricordiamo
o nel futuro, quando pensiamo
a cosa potrà succedere.
E attenzione che, questa seconda cosa
la facciamo in continuazione.
I nostri cervelli sono programmati per
pensare continuamente al futuro.
Il problema è che per farlo
utilizzano gli stessi strumenti
che utilizza per per pensare al passato.
E questo fa sì
che noi facciamo molta fatica
a immaginare un futuro
radicalmente diverso dal nostro presente
soprattutto un futuro migliore,
radicalmente migliore
e diverso dal nostro presente.
A questo punto io so cosa state pensando
Fabio, ma tu sei venuto qua
a darci   solo cattive notizie oggi?
No, vi giuro che c’è anche
una buona notizia,
e la buona notizia è che tra tutte le cose
che l’evoluzione ci ha dato in eredità,
ce n’è anche una che è tipicamente umana,
e che può aiutarci
nella lotta alla crisi climatica
ed è la nostra capacità
di fluire e creare storia.
Noi siamo letteralmente
dipendenti dalle storie.
Anche quelli tra voi,
che magari non leggono tanti romanzi
o non guardano serie tv
e  non amano il cinema.
Tutti utilizziamo le storie per raccontare
un aneddoto a un nostro amico.
Per ancorare la nostra dottrina religiosa.
Utilizziamo le storie anche per parlare
di calcio, l’epica calcistica
e addirittura quando sogniamo,
il nostro cervello continua a propinarcene
in forma di sogno.
Ma com’è che l’evoluzione,
che è sempre così parsimoniosa,
ha fatto sì che noi dedichiamo
così tanto tempo ed energie
a cose che non esistono?
Il punto è che le storie
si sono sviluppate come sistema
per trasmettere esperienze
in maniera immersiva.
Sono praticamente delle palestre
dove noi possiamo fare esperienza
di qualcosa che non abbiamo vissuto
e quindi prendere in prestito
un’esperienza altrui, uno sguardo altrui.
E quindi,
se è vero che la crisi climatica non può
essere abbracciata con un solo sguardo,
è vero che noi possiamo
prendere in prestito quelli degli altri
e sovrapporli per avere
una visione più profonda.
Ed è anche vero che possiamo imparare
a raccontarci un futuro diverso,
un futuro non necessariamente cupo,
un futuro in cui la decarbonizzazione
ha reso questo mondo
più vivibile e più equo.
E di fronte a un’immagine come questa,
una Venezia radicalmente diversa
da quella che conoscete,
ma comunque riconoscibile,
il nostro cervello può andare
in due direzioni.
Può pensare che si tratti
di una storia di fantascienza.
Oppure può pensare che sia un progetto
fattibile, un progetto realistico.
Ci vuole uno sforzo in più
per andare nella seconda direzione,
ma è uno sforzo che possiamo fare.
È uno sforzo che dobbiamo fare.
Perché, se è vero che il mondo si cambia
ai tavoli internazionali
e si cambia arginando
i grandi inquinatori,
è anche vero che prima di tutto
dobbiamo imparare a cambiarlo qua dentro.
Grazie.